[Música]
y en directo ahora vamos hasta la
capital Argentina con el periodista
Ludovico Mori con quien discutiremos
sobre la Cumbre del c40 un evento que
reúne a más de 100 alcaldes de ciudades
de todo el mundo y que tiene como
objetivo encontrar soluciones colectivas
para combatir la crisis climática
Ludovico Gracias por acompañarnos
cuéntenos Cuáles son los puntos
principales de la agenda de la Cumbre
Buenas noches Andrés
los puntos de la Cumbre Son variados son
muchos los temas en discusión pero dos
en particular son los puntos principales
de la agenda y los ilustró esta mañana
el alcalde anfitrión de la Cumbre el
alcalde de Buenos Aires Horacio
Rodríguez larreta se trata del
compromiso punto número uno del
compromiso para la reducción de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
esto teniendo en cuenta que las áreas
metropolitanas en el mundo son
responsables del 70% casi de las
emisiones totales de estos gases un
segundo punto muy importante que también
ilustró la reta esta mañana es
la necesidad de financiar la transición
tecnológica para el desarrollo
sostenible sería muy difícil que las
ciudades sobre todo de los países en Vía
de desarrollo lograsen
estos objetivos de reducción de
emisiones Sin una financiación por parte
de organismos multinilaterales Y esto es
el punto central de que se va a discutir
y que se va a tratar de plasmar también
en una declaración final que es
apuntó la la posibilidad de que las
ciudades reciban financiaciones directas
de parte de organismos multilaterales
como el Banco Mundial o el banco
interamericano de desarrollo en el caso
de la región de América Latina
sabe si va a haber un documento oficial
como un documento final Como ocurre en
este tipo de encuentros
sí siempre la recta esta mañana mencionó
el hecho de que es probable que el
viernes
se logre un documento final que fue
bautizado el consenso de Buenos Aires
que trata de parafrasear quizás el
acuerdo de París el concepto de Buenos
Aires debería plasmar
los objetivos de reducciones de
emisiones y también
este punto de la financiación por parte
de organismos multilaterales esto Estos
son digamos los principales objetivos
que se discutieron hoy en la jornada
preliminar de la Cumbre que que arrancó
esta mañana y que va a tener de su día
principal
mañana donde se van a reunir los
alcaldes de las principales ciudades del
mundo